those Hogwarts robes may have looked
roomy but did you realize that the kids
all had their pockets sewn shut because
Tom Felton kept breaking the rules and
speaking of breaking the rules Alan
Rickman made off with more than a few
props from set that he wasn't supposed
to some rules are golden but others were
made to be broken these are all the
rules the Harry Potter cast was meant to
follow Harry Potter fans know best how a
little chocolate can go a long way eight
you'll feel better Tom Felton took this
advice to heart and during the first few
films he used to sneak chocolate and
sweets into the pockets of his Hogwarts
robes some of the other kids even
started to follow his example though Tom
wouldn't give away any of their names
this went against the production's
strict rule against snacking during
filming hours and so the costume
Department came up with a creative
solution to the rule breaking by sewing
up the pockets on the kids robes this
probably came in handy when it came to
handling any theft on set as well we can
imagine though they only started doing
this sometime after The Prisoner of
Azkaban any stars with sticky fingers
still had three whole movies to make
away with some pretty memorable
memorabilia you've probably heard your
favorite Stars talk about taking the
occasional souvenir from set they ended
up making like 15 of them so there's
like just take one but in the case of
Harry Potter taking things from set was
a strict No-No as spoilers still that
didn't stop the actors from trying Jason
Isaacs watched Alan Rickman slip a few
gold coins into his pockets during the
first days of filming at Gringotts bank
which made him feel like he'd be safe to
go up to director David Yates and
politely ask if he could take home one
of the thousands of copies of the daily
Prophet David said yes but when Jason
tried to leave with the paper he was
approached by a set worker who told him
he needed it back Jason may not have
been lucky but Daniel Radcliffe was able
to get away with two pairs of Harry's
glasses while Emma Watson kept her one
her Time Turner and a cloak so this rule
is pretty standard for franchises like
this does anyone remember the time Tom
Holland leaked the poster for end game
no no no no no no stars just aren't
supposed to discuss anything from
filming when they're offset but one
Harry Potter star took that
responsibility further than most Alan
Rickman had a difficult job as it wasn't
always easy to tell what Snape's
intentions were supposed to be because
of this Alan would argue with directors
over how Snape would act early into
filming JK Rowling had helped Alan by
telling him what lies behind the word
always and according to producer David
Heyman there were several times where
Alan would tell directors no I can't do
that I know what is going to happen and
you don't which we imagine must have
been frustrating but not nearly as
frustrating as not being subscribed to
our channel so make sure to hit that
button now to join our party and
speaking of parties you're probably
pretty familiar with this rule from your
school or workplace already The
Producers wanted our cast to be just as
clear-headed and focused on their work
as your boss most likely wants you to be
and so they asked our cast not to party
take in any alcohol or illicit
substances although that didn't stop
well everyone between the ages of 18 and
21 Daniel Radcliffe used to drink as a
means to cope with the immense pressure
of Fame I did become very reliant on it
Daniel swore that he never drank at work
on Harry Potter but would admit that I
went into work still drunk I can point
to many scenes where I'm just gone dead
behind the eyes Daniel was able to quit
in 2010 with the help of friends and
family the last year has been a lot more
manageable and and a lot a lot better I
feel happier we're just glad that nobody
got hurt can you imagine what would have
happened if one of the actors were
injured during filming a sprained knee
alone could have delayed production by
days or even weeks and so the entire
cast was forbidden from playing any
contact Sports and so what did the cast
do instead they golfed Oliver Phelps
revealed that golf was one of the only
Sports we were allowed to do in our
contract because it was relatively quite
safe this led to a number of the actors
developing an obsession and with golf
and they even set up a sort of driving
range using a mat and 150 yard cone at
the other end at Leafs in studios where
the films were made Oliver said he and
his brother James would often hang out
with Rupert Grint there just so long as
they were being careful with everyone
else's things now you gotta respect the
ride we definitely like to think of the
Harry Potter cast as being like a family
and so it's nice to hear that the rumors
from set suggest that Alan Rickman took
Rupert Grint and Matthew Lewis out for
milkshakes one day after filming for the
Goblet of Fire but what should have been
a cute little moment between them turned
into a whole big mess when those
milkshakes wound up all over the back
seat so when Alan bought himself a BMW
at some point during the filming for
Order of the Phoenix he set down the
rule that none of the younger actors
were allowed to touch it control your
emotions but especially not Rupert or
Matthew who were the alleged reasons for
the rule to be put in place in the
beginning and it's a shame too we
imagine they could have used those
milkshake breaks in between studying
just because you're at Wizarding school
doesn't mean you don't have to study the
child stars on the set for Harry Potter
were all required to attend four hours
of tutoring either on or somewhere
nearby the set and considering their
characters were all supposed to be at
school anyway actors who appeared in the
background would often be encouraged to
do their actual homework just to make it
look as realistic as possible according
to all of her films at one point the
director Alfonso challenged our Stars to
write an essay speaking to their
characters and each one of our main
three responded in the most in character
of ways Daniel was proud of his essay
until he saw Emma's 16 pages and Rupert
oh Rupert but while they may have been
normal kids in some ways when it came to
their hair they had far less control
than you would want how attached are you
to your current hairstyle can you
imagine wearing it for the next 10 years
while our stars were filming for Harry
Potter they were under contractual
obligation not to change their
appearance whatsoever this was
especially Troublesome for Tom Felton
who had to touch up his dark roots like
every five or so days just to maintain
Draco Malfoy's bleached blonde look when
filming ended he said that not having to
dye his hair anymore was it's only one
of the greatest reliefs of it all Emma
Watson was another one who struggled
with her hair at the time she referred
to her hair in the first movie as ugly
and just as soon as filming ended she
cut all of her hair off into a pixie cut
she said that she's wanted to do it
since she was about 16. and describes
the haircut as liberating but that isn't
even the only hair related dilemma they
had on set it seems that Hogwarts is
more like a regular school than you'd
think during the filming of the Chamber
of Secrets our young cast dealt with a
serious outbreak of head lice that
changed the way things were done for a
little bit it's hard to say if the hair
Department could have played a role in
the spread as they may have been using
improperly sanitized tools between
actors but that's neither been confirmed
nor denied and really it isn't that
surprising when you consider the fact
that lice tends to gather where children
are anyway according to Daniel Radcliffe
each child actor had to undergo a
thorough lice check before they were
allowed to go on to do any filming so
that it would be dealt with then and
there so they don't get out of hand but
while we're on the topic of Daniel did
you know that he wasn't even Chris
Columbus's first choice to play Harry
this rule affected who was even allowed
to be in the cast when picking out names
to be in the first Harry Potter film
Warner Bros wasn't exactly looking at
the sort of cast you might expect like
they wanted Robin Williams to play
Hagrid and the director Chris thought
that Liam Aiken who played Klaus in
Lemony Snicket's A Series of Unfortunate
Events would make the perfect Harry but
what do those two actors have in common
well for those of you who don't already
know they're both American and JK
Rowling put down her foot to say that
the cast needed to be primarily British
but that doesn't mean that a few
American actors didn't manage to slip
through the cracks like Michigan born
Vern Troyer who took on the role of grip
hook in the first movie before going on
to be replaced by English actor Warwick
Davis so although there may have been a
few troublemakers among the cast making
a way with props they shouldn't it's
nice to see that everyone amongst the
cast tried to remain respectful towards
each other and the rules especially when
it came to Alan rickman's BMW which one
of these strict rules were you the most
surprised to hear the cast had to follow
don't forget to make your thoughts known
in the comment section down below